hey how are you hi i'm good thank you
um i want to know be you know obviously
this has been such a big part of your
life this these movies for so long now
how
what is it meant for you to be a part of
this franchise these films and these
characters
and i'll start with you um it's honestly
been
life-changing like i know that sounds so
dramatic but it's had such
such a big impact on me and on so many
people that i feel so grateful that i've
gone to be part of this for
so many years too that it's it started
so long ago and that we're still
on this journey together and it's so
bittersweet that it's coming to an end
and this chapter is
kind of coming to a close which is so
sad but it's so
it's so crazy thinking back all the
memories that we have together and
everything that we've
built up throughout these years yeah i
feel so grateful
and so lucky that we formed this amazing
family and
we're friends for life now i mean we
still catch up
you know even when we're not on set
together and i know that that will
continue
and feel so grateful for the memories
and the friendships and
also just fell in love with the story
and and playing margot
and like anna said it's bittersweet yeah
um
how satisfied do you feel with how these
characters that are so beloved to you so
beloved to the fans
how it all wraps up how how do you think
the fans are gonna react
i think i think the third movie is a
great closing chapter
and i think you're gonna see lara jean
she kind of it comes to an end but she
also begins a new chapter in this movie
i think that's really
cool and special and be up to the fans
imagination to
picture her at college and picture where
all these characters go after and
i think it's a really sweet closing i
hope i hope they like it
it's a beautiful ending it definitely is
i i know for myself he's such a huge fan
i was like that's exactly what i wanted
to have happen
so it was perfect um
yeah the feel too yeah oh good good
um you know with this film coming out a
few days before valentine's day i have
to ask you guys have any
plans for valentine's day any love and
lockdown plans
chanel i'm actually going to be
quarantining in canada so
i will have a nice little face face time
date with my husband that's amazing well
i didn't
are you in canada for a project coming
up yeah yeah
oh that's so exciting okay well you have
to get like poutine you have to like at
least celebrate with some of our bad
canadian food good food
i will show her all of all the things
yeah you know
i think zoom dates will be happening in
a lot of households with a lot of people
and my i love valentine's day and i love
like
i'll probably make a card for like my
family members and we might like put up
hearts or something in the kitchen just
because it's fun and i
i like get so excited for days like this
so i'm excited for this year
i'm the exact same way any reason to
just eat more chocolate than i need to
right
honestly yes absolutely that's all i'm
saying um
you you both may have had different
final days of shooting but what was that
final day on set like for each of you we
had
the same day it was it was a final wrap
day for a lot of us and it was in korea
and we were shooting very late night in
this food market
and we were eating handmade noodles that
were made by this
incredible korean uh noodle chef and it
was just
it was so crazy it was wild that we were
like this is first of all
this is our jobs we're like this is
amazing we're in korea eating noodles
late night with like our best friends
what the heck like it was the best and
yes just so so bittersweet when they
finally called that last rap
yeah we got to hold each other when they
said that's a picture wrap on
the three sisters and our family and it
was just like
we could not have pictured a more
perfect ending to
these years of filming this franchise
together oh i love that so much well
congratulations on the film i can't wait
for everyone to see it and
it was so nice talking to you both thank
you thank you nice to meet you
nice to meet you see you later
you